I'm speaking to mr.
Bill talents and who worked on the sydney
harbour bridge approaches as a concrete
a who is that correct. Mr thomson. Yes i
worked as in the concrete gang material is
getting these local and we kept the
materials up to the concrete mixers was
a dumping materials. Yes. Metal sand and
cement. Did you do that in rickshaws
or. You know what her way and that made
a lorries quite a lot on the job quite
a big job at the corner and
all those big arches took
a lot of material i met on the sands and
there. Where did you start first. I
started on the north side
and and i was stationed
where the north sydney railway station
is the day i think it was originally
and depot good yard there and that's where
the start of the tunnel where they had
already been built and in the tunnel was
one tunnel that went over the other
tunnels into those account my spin the
plans at that particular time. But there's
no eventuated of the tunnel still there
that they need to be used as i know what do
you did you start. I started in
nineteen twenty. Seven i think it was
early twenty seven or late 20s. So the
station was already operating then they put
the tunnel. You know was not rating not
for goods. Didn't you didn't just come in
through the rail. Oh yeah but the you
know it was there. Exactly. Before the
project started. I think they built the
tunnel the first up that i performed my
time. Yes. Oh i know that dr.
Bread rolls writings he said that the
first thing to do was to get the tunnels
through so that they could use them for
bringing in materials that they did that
they didn't tell me that who took
you on first and i would know
i don't say i got the job through i was
and you sort of follow the storm and back
as up which was
a seasonal job and in the wintertime
with no work and in the hall and i
used to. Keep in touch with
the union office in the trays
all through casual and one particular
day i was there and i think mr.
Gardner garden he had
a meeting for the unemployed
and how that meeting. I got
a notice to report for
a job i was on the bridge and i
thought myself then that i was going
to work on the bridge itself and i
reported to them. The long on the
north side of the harbour and they
directed me to the public works i
didn't know anything about and so and
along and when i heard about the public
works i said see this will do me
a government stroke. You
know but that was it figures
a mistake i ever made it work too hard to
do i say you know there. When so i was in
you know material again and the brain and
all of material the sand the metal and
the some hand through the tunnels. Whenever
i come from into this depot and the
gang high we used to empty the railway track
in the lorry and lorry used to take it
to the mixers. So that all shovel work
was shovel work and home issues and then
days. Remember you're going to do your
boss. Yeah that's happened they made
charlie peach. I think he's dead now. What
was he like you. Nice chap but he was
a little you know days so i don't think
he last that long here. Now do you shovel
as well. Oh no. Now he he never shall of
the director who haggis and that i now.
But i've got a picture of
a fellow an old fellow who was
in that that yard area them
a start and used to wear
a waistcoat white shirt. Yeah
they could be him but there was
a right and you know just tie and i think
he name is bill was his first name not
shepherd here that i built shepherd. Well
he was the foreman of all the public
works on both sides. That's why and why i
remember bill shepherd was that. Do you
mean that in our job and unloading
the trucks every day every
evening. You get
a truckload. Trainload of trucks line and
they are job doing so well on
a friday. On the friday that trucks had
come in about three or four o'clock and
if they were kept over the weekend the
public work you have to pay the railway
people demurrage so much extra on
the truck see this pretty hard
you know work and all day. You know you
know there was officially in the summertime
when night down the hole and it's pretty
warm you know that i was young and silly
and i've led to work and because no times
it was suppression to actually was
depression time you know
a lot of unemployed and i was pleased
i just been married i pleased to have
a job and i didn't say i die at the work
the dolans i got out what happened. But
when four o'clock come and the late young
come in. Bill shepherd used really up all
the other trucks and all the other get
a different gauge you know and bring it
up to help. But they're doubly hard is
going to get the tax unloaded
by the time you know
your time and bill shepherd i
know member now clearly he is
a run up and down attacks and if you just
stood up and straighten your back. You
think you'd hear somebody sing out get in
there. We'll get out there. You got the
thing and in them they were talking
about public works and you know and the
government started well that was
a mistake on my bar but part on that i
found you know the job pretty good.
Tell me the bridge approach is there when
you you loaded the trucks and you also
did you unload at the cement mixers and
that's only so i meant because i guess the
tip that they used to tip the metal in the
sand but the cement used to be stacked
alongside them. So you were used to go
with the trucks you ask first unload the
railway wagons onto the onto
the road trucks to do well
where we wouldn't go anywhere with the
sand on the metal but the people whose and
some in gang which i was one we had done
load the track with us. I meant. And
if the cement board with
a mix or i was empty. We keep the bags on
and we'd take from the truck too but if
not they had
a shed in the yard. Especially for the
sump bags i meant and we used to put the
surplus in in the so we them to take it
out of the trucks or so in actual fact
there was no road trucks you were going
straight from the rower trucks to the
cement mixer. Shed. And
if if there are no railway tracks well
natalie if i get out of the shed. How many
mixers were there on the spot
that i wouldn't now. I think
three or four with
a one cubic garden sheens or the bigger big
consumer i mean being that i didn't go
into details and you know when i
was pretty hard our chaps had
a pretty hard job clean. You know where
there is the cement mixers all the cement
mixers for the northern approaches where
there are only for the north idea that's
tied and south side there are you know depot
and where the cement was mixed it you
know just how they handled it gently
went into burrows and was tracked to the
site that was they bring the cement
mixer up near the case of the job
pole
a course on and they work on that but
then how did these cement. When when that
happened. Did you have to go out with it
and deliver the stuff. When you mean. Well
if they move the cement mixer up you'd have
to do you move the material as well and
i want to say when when they finish their
job they generally finished up most of
the material you know they wouldn't take
more than what they required and they
don't have
a little bit of you know at that shift
that the ship there because they had all
those big walls you know and they approach
it from down the bottom or three out
right up the bridge down up to the arches
and they wouldn't know moved too far.
Once i went clear in my
mind although i've seen
a lot of photographs on how they did it.
I haven't got it clear in my mind where
the what where you moved the cement to
cement and sand and metal and also where the
. There's a bent mix as were did
the cement mixers move up with
a job in which case did they use our trucks
to move it up to them or what did they
do. Oh no. The the mixers we're on
wheels and they be pulled on by
a wagon lorry thing and whenever they go
over there. We couldn't news any railway
track macaws have no rails. You know. So
what did you do then. And so what do you
do then to get the sound of metal and
cement up to the mixer you unloaded it from
railway trucks and then what
the road as already formed
a dirt road we already formed and enough
of the trucks motor trucks used to take
the material up the mixer and tippet out
on the board. You know and you would go
and with them and unload the cement only
the summit yeah the summit. And because
all the while the only be when they needed
us i mean that we had you know the metal
in the sand was the biggest part they needed
more so when we went back and those i
meant when we got back into the tracks
unload trucks i meant wealthy and whatever
may be you know how many hours
a day to do work those days eight days
it out. I think forty forty four starter
forty four forty four. I think we know
what union we're you in i thin the
w
w that the dime and my gang. I
mean about the travel. What
do you want no strikes no less don't work.
We now have few disputes we and i would
shed. For our change quarters and whenever
it rained we came in and the water be
floating around the food to be float
around the money and we jacked up
a couple of times but we got
a bit of attention so we never never
had to resort to someone work and who
did you see when there was this dispute who
did you go and see and oh we report at
the gang at charlie peach and he deported
back to the office and they'd send some
money out. Jim meeting any of the public
works engineers. I can't say i did.
I don't remember any many other gang of
even on the job only one up sticks in my
mind as charlie let's remember him
at all. Mention that big chap he was
a ganger on one other material concrete
or what was he like oh he's like
again if you know yet that
to you at the job. Was
a i've i've heard. I've heard
a few stories about public works going as
re. Them being not. Not too particular
about the way they handle people looking
for jobs or even people had jobs
threatening them with wanting something out
of their pay or what anything do i come
across like anything like that nothing at
all at all. Now i'd be up against that
state and would go. You know who had
been one union stickin up myself. And if
anything like that happen and i was one
person and yes and i had the one yeah
wasn't my gang of they we went down to
help them out there and there you know
a feeling that when they used to do the
archway that used to be the biggest job
because when they started on the arch they
had to do the whole lot. That's lavender
street art and if it's right there will
allow and i see. Well we have the arch was
finished and we are down doing the roadway
and this particular gang. You see get in
the middle of the roadway where you
could see and hear the footy foot up on
something and they wouldn't move for hours.
I mean you know and it's not necessary
to you know stand over i mean like that.
You know that when i see the men on the
job they all did this year they said
before there were no public. No government
stroke in the do you remember anybody in
the union did you have anything to do with
the secretaries and anybody like them you
know only pay me money and i play in the
office that was all and that's one of the
top. No he didn't want the union. I think
i think we don't he. He went up
a parliament he got elected about you in
the you travel. Do you meet anybody that
particular line. What he where did you
work on the north side of the bridge.
No not not come across anybody mentioned
somebody who went later went into
parliament that was working on the on the
northern approaches and they said might
have been i didn't know i wasn't in touch
with him personally but i know that you
know everybody was glad that he might
have worked for he might have been
a official of the new year. Only then
something everyday i know i don't know the
member for north sydney at that
time was name was ben how he was
a tramway man he came from the tramway
workshops and he went back there after he
was defeated in an election. I know
about him and in the city the member of
parliament at that time was no same
as kline then kline and he was
fully restored and packers.
I'm a stone and they guy was
a delegate for the storm and
back with me and then klein yeah
. And i worked alongside billy brother he
was i think it's either the fact as an
early part of my life. Tell me.
Also read the bridge again
on the day they poured the airing
of lavender street art which was
a world record at that time were you in
on that you know that i was kept in some
end up timer on the boards and those
particular davie used to start earlier think
that he evolve extra. Over time. Of
course and very welcome those days
and boys just earned their money on the.
It was hard work just one or four board to
actually medal and say in shoveling into
the mix. Oh yeah shall and i mean you know
i never done that much of that myself and
do you remember the quantity that was
done in that in that arch ring that day i
can't idea. As i should put it on record
. I don't have it with me actually. But i
should put it on record and but i know
that it was
a record at that time and it was the
lavender street arch wasn't it yet. That's
right. Yes i remember that they did say
that they missed so many bags i mean it
used in particular for what time did you
get finished that they owe i think if he's
around about six o'clock in the issue then
where did you know fifty or do you know
where did you go then. Did you go straight
home or did you go over the pope. Oh at
the public eye which but was it. We had
one right on the job right outside the
depot. I think that they are
that not there now because
well can i take you back for your memory
thing more on the on the on the bridge
approach is there anything outstanding
any accident. At least how only thing
outstanding. I i remember was one
particular day one afternoon
of getting ready to knock off and just
in the change room at the bottom of the
morning walk
a street i thrown where the picture shows
used to be and still is and we looked
across the harbor and we saw. So all the
people struggling in the water with the ax
and all the great lift and
that the laws. That stand out
in my memory and how that no accident on
the job and the only when i run. I mean we
are an accident when we were when those xo
bait and for the stairs in the mountains
point. Railway station. I
would happen to be. Down i
mean in our spike spare time when they're
down material to go where you go with the
other games and roadway and things like
that help out. Keep that occupied and was
actually late and this what you go
on and then x of eight and back and
a lot of the day and you know and i went
to steady it and buying that i got me
a hand caught in the clip and i lost that
even the finger part of me as in bedded
in the bridge somewhere. Yes i see it's
a top joint you lost seven eight seven
eight and they are going to like you get
compo for that. Yeah yeah.
ninety to ninety dollars in
a ninety pound i mean those day than the
insurers reckon i only lost seven eight of
a deal and so i only got seven eights and
ninety dollars. Do you member any other
serious accidents remember fatalities
they're not on and on they're pros. Kate i
heard occasion when going off
a bridge you know there was
a carpenter and on the fitzroy that
collapsed and he lost his life. I don't
remember them. And in addition to that
there was somebody working there were
wrecked in a crane and that taking the
crane apart crane parts off a truck with
a shear legs and suddenly one leg of the
share legs collapsed into the earth and it
turned over on him killing and immediately.
You know i heard about that but i was
nowhere near that you know about eyewitness
account of it. And one bloke got killed
in the train and work by
a tram working in the street there as well.
Yeah i didn't know that because i did
say and i started in 1927 saying
well it was going well before i
was well advanced when i. And then
twenty seven was well advanced
you know they've been working some time
when i don't know what time they started
you know the approach that there were
nineteen twenty seventeen in the
1930 to us there after the bridge was
one of the last ones to go. Where you
were you in the procession on the day
the bridge opened and yeah you know
processional right and we got
a crowd of it to that day. Yeah i remember
the mob on the fence you know to get i
guess all the crystal ball in the margin
you know everybody would wait you see
they'd all be on the bearded with
a cool day and it wasn't too good not
black and so it happened that you know
somewhat out the empty out and that's where
they do that over the fence just at the
start of the style of the bridge whether
the time was like we need to we need
anybody else and you have
nobody to quite ok got quite
a lot. You should see that fence but do
you remember actually marching in the
procession. I went right over the ridge
yeah i did march back to him because i
lived in granny's at the time and i have
to for home at anybody calling out do
you really well you were marching in the
position i can't say i did you know one of
the blokes remembered them calling out to
him you will soon be on the dole my. Only
i had nobody to cheer me up. Wouldn't you
do you know i'll leave at that you know
i was lucky that i able. I was there as
a storm and packer that i was able to
win in the seas and i was able to get
a job. Casual job in the hall and you know
used to work and all stores and used to
work and whenever the oil
companies had a ship and
a tin tin of it. They go and they kerosene
and spirits and things like that. I you
know it was a chance of picking up
a week's work and it was good money. You
know the casual work was good money. You
know even today. Where were you born. Mr.
Tom in roselle remember the
rez elin the new younger
i thought you know i'm reminded camperdown
and petersham i've been away ever played
. You've always you go to school and
i went to the camperdown school and
my son went there you know
what i remember the you
know we would be your time want to say the
game of the umpire no use in you still
have a bit of
a bizarre and you know turn out for the
kids and quite quite the do we used to get
you know from the father because of the
school year been like they sort of ha get
now when we are born born in february
1984 and you went to school. It can be
downright and when your going to be about
eight or nine i think. Do you remember
cambered and there's
a do you live in canada. I lived in la
and waverly how did you manage to go to
school in canberra oh well that i forget
now i how or what happened how it was
that your father or mother must of worked
over in camperdown you know if father
used he was
a storeman too and the same trouble you
know they had at work and the mood at the
time i remember used to go around sellin
apples and when the fare used to be on and
they would be awful apples to then
see too many of the day. Yeah. So
do you remember well aware you left. Yeah.
What do you remember about it. Anything
now. I mean you know you know i don't
know. Only by skill days i used to gether
larus girl and i used to live in waverly
and i moved from well into. What
waverly and i used to travel
waverly to the largest school in days. And
then you move somewhere else and then we
do it to move to guilford then i went to
the guilford school that was we moved out
about nineteen fifteen or sixteen
hours out went on the law and
then we moved the south granville and
we moved back to petersham and know
the day i start i domy work
then when i start to get
a job. Oh they'll than i think they do all
and after you started straight away as
a stone back at it. I was. Yeah i did start
on the back of the tie and i was only
allowed and i got a job in a while
still in the form of a father was
a branding boy. Yes the
brand all the nails
a dollar going overseas
you know and used to get
a lot of legal me figure and you know bring
in the i got you know all the ever he
never be clear i think and i learn the
piano at the time i start that they got
up and used to go the leather found the
guest used to get that's all. But when you
get
a bit warm legal challenge to get you know
how to get the piano up anyway. Anyway i
went away from the storm and he came and i
mean you'd enjoy another boot warehouse
and i boots. It was a used i just saw it
out. The other day for john who was on
a wall of a building was
pulled down and there was
a sign up there john. I understand it's
a pretty boots half guinea boots.
Oh yes they had quite a. Quite
a few lots of boots and those
days and they had a warehouse and
a factory in medicine in my
days and did you do there
i was aware ours when you know even the
stock and want to go on send and just like
in
a shop to see them take the shoes in and put
them in their particular racks and that
and then when anybody sent anybody and yet
their acts and send out the particular
shooter the customer and when i become
twenty one and got full money or they kicked
me out there. They didn't believe they and
you know what do you would that be when
the 1920 too much for do you
do you remember you were working as
a stone backer during the during the war
where you know not you at all. Now what
you're working at all and only fourteen and
only only fifteen i think when the war
ended 1918 i'd be 14th in
a ball and i for the 1918 the war ended.
You know fourteen. Do you remember the
upheavals of the 1917 strike. I remember i
am i started i started work that's why i
started work when i thirty and
half actually i worked in garages
in town and polishing cars and cleaning up
and things like that and that's i remember
the strike. I mean because of that but
at the time i had a buy
a pair of boots and the job i had. There's
pretty wet you hoes and the car down and
i thought to be a good idea to buy up
a strong booze me i'm wrong blucher
boots and i mean but try and i out and
i wore an all day and they
blistered me bloomin feet and
going home when i got the time and i had
the stands on the rail over most angelo
most aged up to granville and that's
a father saying when they had
a walk from granville to guilford to get
home and i tell you my first produced
a thing that sticks in my memory about you
know trying to do that save myself the
money and i lost
a lot of skin froze there anybody you
know involved in the in the seventeen
struggle and you member the family being
being interested in the conscription debate
as well. And it other the way at the
time i think you called up as
a boy soldier. I thought everybody had
to go all the boys had to go into the
compulsory training like theirs i
belong to the militia. That's why i had
a trip to camp to liverpool and i was quite
an experience you enjoy that. Oh yeah
it was alright was a change and
you have to go along. One night
a week as well you know i'd like in
a way that i i. After i went to camp after
i had to camp i come back and i put me in
uniform you know and all the gear in and
i supposed to report to back
on the job. I suppose in
a certain time and anyway i got to go. I
never heard any more about it. I didn't do
any more training. Nobody
want i could have been
a good soldier could i say. You know i
think it was doing. Do you remember during
the depression time. You know how it was
for you. I mean did you get less work
because of the because of the depression
that strawman back. Oh yeah yeah. P
opposition and
a you know we on the dole. We were on the
dole and i'm now i would say yes only
do about i'd be lucky if i get six months
in the years he will you can then up and
six months
a lark you know the other think month and
again cause the dole wasn't that you
could say in the first part i remember
which i didn't have to experience yourself
was that you used and i
used to have to report to
a place at the railway and they used to
dish out the bread and the meat and those
things like that and i'd believe it used
to be you know pretty rough. If you didn't
like it. Well you know you could love it
and the people serving out of course used
to get
a bit cranky and i remember one
particular time we're chap. With
yet need meat. And i mean this is
hearsay mind and that line that
he said hey look at this meeting he said.
How how would you like to take that home
to your wife and the japs and he said i
don't have to and the bank just got the
meet and slap you know faith and
that was their attitude and quite
a you know maybe body one the same i find
it in life and you know you find stinkers
and good bloods you know and how did
you get away in my dealings with
the with the dull was that i
used to have to get the offers
and they used to give me coupons and used
to take the coupons to the graces and the
bakers and the butcher and you get so much
meat on each kid one that. I never in
the state where they got money used to
get about seven and six days worth of
married man and i didn't have any kids then
and how do you get the rent and how did
you get the rent. I wasn't in the best
harbor time i think when the bad times i
lived with
a wife's mother. And i was
paying board and i had to take
a lot up and i tell you when i got
the lump sum from the finger with
a very handy. They and what i owed the
lady at those particular day is quite
pleased i get the money back from you £90
that you lost you talk to your finger.
That's right. So i done this odd bit of
good die. Down and miss the finger that
much that tip and i don't a
good turn the way i had to give
a bit of flesh but deny
a pound of flesh it's not. And do you
remember again before the bridge. How many
times we are out of work every
season. You know well i want to
say i i. Just got casual
work. You know just going to work but
i never thought i was in in the john
until three about three years i think well
i you know when pollen wasn't following
me. Trade i think the packers when you
went down to the. The trades hall.
Was that like
a toeing the line arrangement where you
were you sort of lined up for jobs. No in
our in our particular
union was that they had
a book and if they you signed that signed
the book and she was out of work and
every week.